yeah well you know it's going worldwide
to be was honest
oh
good
um
okay
okay
um
230.
is
candy
oh
sorry
we were afraid
it's coming
okay
okay
i'm thank you
okay
uh
right
okay
go ahead over here
hi everyone happy monday
okay uh our special guest today
is our director of the national economic
council brian diese uh
and he will be as you may know uh brian
was senior advisor to president obama
and previously served as acting director
of the office of
management and budget and in the obama
biden administration brian helped
coordinate policy development for tax
policy housing
clean energy manufacturing and the
automotive industry
brian has agreed to come despite having
the unenviable task of
not being able to roll out many details
of our joint session speech or the
american family's plan but
we still wanted to have him here to
provide some context and some of the
questions you all had raised
and he'll only be able to take a couple
questions but
thank you uh jen and it's uh it's good
to see you all um
again so i wanted to just provide a
little bit of context
uh around uh in particular capital gains
uh taxes
um and we'll provide just a little bit
of context and then happy to take a
couple of questions
so as you know and as jen has spoken
about the president
is excited to this week um lay out his
plan to invest in american families um
it will be a plan that will provide
critical support for children and
families
and in by doing so critical support for
our economy
by boosting labor force participation
and future economic competitiveness
making among the most cost-effective
measures to boost our long-term economic
strength
that we know of and the president will
also outline ways to offset the
long-term costs of those investments by
making reforms to our tax code
that reward work and not just wealth
and one element of this reform would be
to change how we tax capital gains
uh in as you all know that's income from
selling stocks and other assets
uh for taxpayers that make more than one
million dollars per year
um in income so i want to start by
reinforcing who this change will
actually affect
this change will affect taxpayers making
more than a million dollars a year
in 2018 three tenths of one percent
of tax filers made more than a million
dollars a year
so i want to start by underscoring this
in simple terms
this change will only apply to three
tenths of a percent
of taxpayers um which is not the top one
percent
uh it's not even the top one half of one
percent uh we're talking about three
tenths of a percent
that's about 500 000 households
uh in the country that we're talking
about so for the other
997 out of a thousand households in the
country
uh or the other 150 million households
in the country
this is not a change that will be
relevant it won't change their
uh the tax treatment of capital gains at
all
um and this makes sense because for the
typical americans
most of their income comes from wages
so for people making less than 100 less
than a million dollars a year about 70
percent
of their income comes from wages
but for those making more than a million
for the top three tenths of a percent
it's
the opposite about thirty percent of
their wages come from
uh uh wages um and that's probably
actually an understatement since the
wealthiest
can often strategically avoid reporting
this type of income
uh entirely and so as a result
this is this is the provision that since
2000 if you look at the
1400 tax filers those are people making
over 60
million dollars a year that's the uh for
those of you
keeping track that's the top one
thousandth of one percent
um they have only paid about 20 of their
reported income in taxes
so their tax rate which probably is
overstated again because this is the
category that
often doesn't report or under reports
income
their tax rate is lower than many
middle class families tax rate this is
the dynamic that led
warren buffett uh to famously explain
that he paid a lower tax rate
than his secretary and it's the
uh it is the dynamic that has led the
president and others
to argue that we need to do something
about
equalizing the taxation of work and
wealth
in this country and that's why the
reforms that the president will lay out
are focused on this top
sliver of people and treating capital
gains the same as wages for the top 3
tenths of a percent
and we believe that it's not only fair
but it would also
help to reduce the kinds of tax
avoidance
that significantly under under
undermines
trust and fairness in the tax code
itself
and importantly the the revenue from
this provision would invest
would help invest directly in our kids
and our families and our future economic
competitiveness
and put us in a position where we can
drive greater economic
growth um so we'll we'll have more to
say
on this and how it fits into the overall
plan um
but i i just wanted to uh re-underscore
at the top
that that number one uh we're talking
about uh
as a tax change that would affect again
the three-tenths of one percent
uh the top sliver of households
um and number two the principle here is
to equalize the treatment
of ordinary income and capital gains um
and that is a principle that's
neither um new nor particularly
novel in fact the the last president to
enact
a uh reform to equalize the treatment of
uh ordinary income and capital gains was
president reagan
uh who uh did so while raising capital
gains taxes as part of the 1986
tax reform um and of course we will be
raising to uh higher rates than in that
reform
uh but a lot has changed in the economy
uh since then a lot has changed in the
academic and empirical research
in this space but the the principle is
the same which is that for the very
uh highest income americans we should
tax at the same rate ordinary income and
capital gains
so with that when i pause and could take
a couple of questions
thanks so much for doing this brian just
to make sure i understand this
critics say that you tax capital gains
lower rates
to incentivize investments that help the
economy grow
is the administration's perspective that
among these high earners
they have not been making the
investments to help the economy and that
the government programs can do it better
so across a wide body
of academic and empirical evidence there
is no evidence of a significant impact
of capital gains rates on the level of
long-term investment in the economy
if you look back over the last 30 or 40
years we've had capital gains rates at
various rates
we've seen different levels of
investment and overall economic growth
you can't identify a meaningful
correlation
between the two there's lots of reasons
for that
including that if you look at where
a lot of venture capital and early stage
investment comes from it actually comes
from
pension funds sovereign wealth funds
entities that actually are not
um tax sensitive uh also because
at the end of the day a lot of things go
into making an investment
decision but certainly our view
and reading of the evidence is that
there is not a there's not a correlation
that would significantly affect
investment
for these highest income individuals
number one and number two
we can use those resources to invest in
areas
that we know where there is convincing
academic evidence empirical evidence
that investments for example in early
childhood
and in our children return
enormous dividends uh in terms of their
own academic success
reduce costs in the healthcare system
productivity
uh and growth in the future
uh brian one question on the family's
plan itself um why
isn't the white house including a plan
to reduce the price of prescription
drugs in the plan
the good news about a question like that
is i get to tell you that
since we haven't rolled out the family's
plan yet uh and uh
and i'm not going to do it at the podium
right now
um i am not going to confirm uh whether
or not uh that
is uh is in i could you know say that
the president has
long focused on the the issue of
rising costs of prescription drugs for
american consumers and american families
it's something that he continues to
focus on and prioritize but i'm going to
let him speak to those issues
in the speech andrew yeah friend
so on the question of um how you enact
this
so it's i mean is this capital gains tax
increase
dead on arrival when it comes to the
hill the republicans are screaming
that it is not a a good proposal there's
even some concerns in democratic circles
how do you convince people that this
makes sense
well i i would say a couple of things to
that the first is
on the um on the facts and on the
evidence to go to the conversation we
were just having
that um we think that the the the best
read of the
uh of the evidence is actually that i'm
making this sort of change for
that top you know three tenths of a
percent of taxpayers
uh equalizing ordinary income and
capital gains is
uh is would restore fairness and do so
in a way that wouldn't
uh significantly affect investment and
that would allow us to make
really high return investments uh for
which there's been
broad bipartisan support so we think
that that's a
a pretty sensible way of going at it
number one number two is
the president has said in the context of
the jobs plan and the corporate tax
reform plan
and we'll say in the context of this
plan as well he is laying out
his jobs plan and his family's plan this
is his vision for how we need to
put in place a public adjust investment
agenda for the country
he is also identifying ways to
responsibly pay for it
and he is welcoming and encouraging
others to come forward with their
ideas as well are you going to need
reconciliation to do this
i think what you're going to hear from
the president is a call
to consider these investments and the
potential that they would provide for
the country
and engage in a serious conversation
about both whether these investments are
needed and if we can agree that they're
needed how we're going to offset their
cost
he's starting that conversation where he
believes it's a responsible place to
start by putting a plan on the table and
we'll take the conversation from there
i want to pick up on something you
mentioned about investing in kids and
ask you about the child tax credit not
specific to the american family's plan
but just in general
some of the president's democratic
allies on the hill as you well know have
pushed to make that permanent they say
they've faced some
resistance and push back from the
administration what's the argument
against making it permanent is it
economic or is it political
in that democrats potentially might want
to run on this in 2024 and if you make
it permanent it robs democrats
well let me start by making the argument
for the
expanded and fully refundable child tax
credit because
it was uh president biden
who put a temporary one-year expansion
of the child tax credit in his american
rescue plan
which he announced on january 14th
seven days before he was even
inaugurated and it was president biden
who worked with congress and fought to
get that enacted into law and now as a
result
uh the american families uh
families with of 66 million children
will receive a fully refundable expanded
child tax credit this year
uh and that will be uh be delivered
monthly uh going forward and the best
estimates are that
that uh in combination with the other
elements of the rescue plan
will reduce child poverty uh by 50 by
about 50
this year so president biden is both um
incredibly proud of that accomplishment
and the
uh uh and the speed with which we were
able to implement
and believes that we should extend uh
that
uh that that policy to provide
uh some certainty and stability to those
families who will be relying on that
uh payment but would see it go away if
congress doesn't act
so that's the context for it and i'll
let the president speak to
the specific plan in the joint session
speech
he will come back will other people but
brian's got to go
sorry brian thank you for coming uh and
he'll come back soon
it's always so much easier for me to
play good cop now i realize why
i know i take all your questions but
yeah
okay come on back um
right exactly well there'll be much more
to say when we roll out the speech okay
a couple of items additional items for
all of you at the top
today the u.s department of agriculture
and secretary vilsack announced the
historic
expansion of the summer pandemic ebt
program
this is the single largest summer child
nutrition effort in our nation's history
and will reach more than 30 million kids
this summer
thanks to the american rescue plan
summer feeding programs are considered a
lifeline for some
families but until now they've reached
less than 20 percent of families served
during the school year
children are eligible for this program
if they are eligible to receive free or
reduced price meals
during the school year or if they are
under age six and live in a snap
household that is about 34 million
american children
parents or guardians do not need to take
any action to receive the cards
in the mail from their state agencies
each child will receive a 375 dollar
credit loaded onto an ebt card and can
then
that they can that can then be used by
parents or guardians to purchase
food also today president biden will
sign an executive order
establishing the white house task force
on worker organizing and empowerment
this task force is a historic effort to
mobilize the federal government's
programs policies and practices to
empower workers to organize
and collectively bargain with their
employers and will have a specific focus
on increasing worker power in
marginalized and underserved communities
vice president harris will be chair of
the task force and secretary of labor
marty walsh will be the vice chair
the task force will include more than 20
cabinet members and department
heads also vice president harris
and will will have a bilateral meeting
with the president of guatemala
this afternoon they'll meet virtually to
discuss working together to address
immediate relief needs of the guatemalan
people as well as deepening cooperation
on
migration the vice president will also
participate
in a round table with representatives
from the guatemalan community-based
organizations
tomorrow vice president harris's direct
engagement is a testament to the
importance
we are placing on improving conditions
in guatemala
when the vice president spoke last with
the president of guatemala on march 30th
they agreed to collaborate on promoting
economic development leveraging
technology
strengthening climate resist resilience
and creating the conditions to expand
opportunity for people in their home
countries in order to address the root
causes
of migration finally as you may have
also
seen today we announced that the
administration is looking at options to
share american-made astrazeneca vaccine
doses
during the next few months given the
strong portfolio of vaccines that the
united states has already authorized
and available in large quantity and that
is available in large quantities
including two two two dose vaccines and
one
one dose vaccine and given astrazeneca
is not authorized for use in the united
states
we do not need to use astrazeneca in our
fight against covid over the next
few months before any astrazeneca doses
are shipped
from the united states the fda will
confirm any such doses meet its
expectations for product
quality this is being done in the
context of the fda's ongoing
review of all doses made at the plant
where these astrazeneca doses were
produced
and i anticipate in the near future our
team will share more details
about our planning and uh who will be
receiving doses from here
but we're in the planning process at
this point in time
josh go ahead thanks jen uh let's go to
india
and what they're dealing with with the
quran admirers the president just spoke
with the prime minister of india
can you give us more details about that
and in terms of
how many supplies what are we really
going to rush out there what's the
volume in the scale to deal with the
problem
sure well uh as josh noted and you may
have all seen the readout that we just
put out but just in case you didn't the
president spoke
today with prime minister modi of india
committing that the united states and
india will continue to work closely
together in the fight against kovid
the president pledged america's
steadfast ongoing support for the people
of india
who have been impacted by the recent
surge in the covid19
cases in response we have provided and
let me give you more of a specific
update and i'll also note for you that
there'll be an additional call
later this afternoon that will provide
additional details so this is just what
is available at this point in time
of what is being requested and what we
are providing so
there are a number of areas that have
are of great interest and
are great need to india at this point in
time oxygen is one of them
at india's request we are exploring
options to provide
oxygen and related supplies department
of defense and usaid
are pursuing options to provide oxygen
generation systems
we may be in a position to reroute
shipments planned for other countries
with lower immediate needs
given the urgency of the conditions in
india and we'll have more
details hopefully on the possibility
soon dod is also exploring providing
field oxygen generation systems
which we have used in our field medical
hospitals each unit can provide
oxygen for up to 50 to 100 beds
and we're also exploring options to
provide oxygen concentrators
and ventilators and are in technical
discussions with india to ensure the
equipment we supply can connect to
indian devices
the united states has already provided
200
ventilators to india last year and
trained medical professionals on
their use so this is of course in
addition to that and other assistance
we've provided another one of the major
needs is ppe
and we've identified us commercial
suppliers
as well and i should say in therapeutics
and tests
but we've identified u.s commercial
suppliers of remsevier that are
immediately available to help relieve
the suffering of covid19 patients in
india
we've identified rapid diagnostic
testing supplies personal protective
equipment
and additional ventilators available to
be transferred to
a media into india immediately and i
noted of course
we also of course are in close touch
with india officials at all levels about
the raw material needs that they have uh
and as requested by india we will
provide raw materials for the production
of astrazeneca
kobe shield vaccine at serum institute
of india i know some of these have been
announced but that's just a little bit
of additional details
so we're an ongoing discussions about
what their needs are and how we can meet
them but go ahead
and then secondly uh the president
issued a 100-day mass mandate for
federal buildings
does the administration plan to update
its mass guidance
now that we're at 100 days roughly of
dividing presidency
and what about for the broader country
what science what research are you using
to guide you
well i know there's been some reports
out about cdc plans and we will
certainly leave it to the cdc to
announce their guidance which i think
was the second part of your question
about what will be required outside um
and when masks will be required for
individuals who have been vaccinated so
we won't get ahead of any uh
final details or announcements they will
make um
you know the president of course issued
that uh at 100 days we're not quite at
100 days so i don't have anything more
to preview for you in terms of what
might be next
go ahead looking ahead to wednesday to
the president's speech before joint
session of congress can you give us a
sense of how the speech is coming
together the president's
involvement in it how he wants to use
that speech um
and his appearance there to to sell the
remainder of his legislative
agenda sure well first the president has
been working over the last couple of
days
as he will be over the next two on his
speech he's deeply involved in
the development of a speech he's
thinking a great deal about what uh
what message he can send directly to the
american people
about what progress we've been made but
of course what challenges remain ahead
he recognizes as somebody who served in
the senate for 36 years that
this is an opportunity one of the
highest profile opportunities even the
president has
each year to speak directly to the
american people and that's exactly what
he intends to do
uh he will lay out the specific details
of the american family's
plan uh in that speech but he will also
talk about
a range of priorities uh that he has for
the uh upcoming months of his presidency
including
uh putting in place uh working with
congress to
place peace reform uh including uh doing
more to expand
access to affordable health care uh so
there will be a range of priorities he
will also mention
uh in his speech but he's deep working
closely with uh his
speech writers on it but also with
policy advisers and policy in the policy
teams and finalizing
the components that will be in this and
in this country what's the level of
concern within the administration that
apparently five million people are about
eight percent of those who got the first
dose of pfizer
and modernity didn't return for for dose
two
well what i'll say is that uh there's no
precedent right there's no
uh playbook and the other way of looking
at that is that we're pleased that the
vast majority or
92 percent of people came back for their
second doses
uh and that is actually a pretty
significant number in our view
uh we know people lead busy lives uh but
the second dose is critical
to getting the maximum level of
protection to help defend against
variants and get people
the longest lasting protection and that
is certainly a message that is being
projected
by our health and medical team and
doctors who are speaking on behalf of
the administration as it was over the
last couple of days
i'll also say that a big part of our
effort as we shift into this
newer stage which less about supply and
more about reaching people
where they are is making it easier to
get vaccinated and that certainly
applies to people have not yet received
their first dose but also applies to
people
getting their second dose so partnering
with doctors offices
setting up walk-up sites helping workers
get paid time off
that's all a part of our effort to
ensure people are
getting both doses of the vaccine if
they're doing the two-dose vaccine
and congratulations and that's
embarrassing you got married i did yes
congratulations welcome back thank you
thank you jen um
first vice president harris says that
she's not gone to the border yet because
we have to deal with covet issues what
is she referring to
uh well i i would certainly have to ask
her team about that specifically but i
would tell you also that
her focus is not on the border it's on
addressing the root causes in the
northern triangle and
that's why the majority of her time has
been spent on
working with on a diplomatic level she
is going to speak
have a bilateral meeting with the
president of guatemala this afternoon
she's going to speak with the president
of mexico next week and she's working
with them
to ensure there are systems put in place
to reduce the
amount of migration coming from these
countries but also to address the root
causes and that's really what the
president asked her to do
then i guess if not with regard to her
specific statement is there a white
house concern when you guys are planning
presidential or vice presidential travel
but more about cobit at the border than
other places that
she has traveled recently uh we
certainly know that
the number of people who are in
facilities the reason we have been so
focused on expediting
moving kids out of these border patrol
facilities is because we want to
uh reduce the public health impact in
these facilities
and get them into spaces where we can do
social distancing and when we can
ensure these kids have access to health
uh
you know health and medical experts and
educational resources so
that's certainly and we've made some
progress on that front even over the
last
few weeks since you got married i will
say uh on that exact issue
so look but if the president or a vice
president goes down
and visits a facility like this you have
to potentially clear some parts out
there's a lot of security that comes our
focus here is on
solutions on making progress on moving
these kids out of these facilities
and getting them connected with sponsor
homes with with family members if
possible
and that's really where the president
president's focus is at this point
about those facilities there was a
report in the last couple days in the
new york post that
every migrant child being brought to a
shelter is being given a copy of her
children's book superheroes are
everywhere
do you know why that is and if she is
making any money off of that
of the president of the vice president's
president's book yeah
i'd have to check with our health and
human services team if
they're talking about if they go to
shelters or if they go to
the welcome kit apparently there's a
copy of her 2019 children's
book superheroes are everywhere i have
to certainly check on that
here it's a good book and then i've got
one more um
why was president buying the only world
leader
at the climate summit zoom who was
wearing a mask
because he is sending a message to the
world that he is
putting in place precautions and
continuing to do that
as leader of the united states and i
don't know what setups they all had in
their countries
that may warrant some more reporting or
not uh but obviously he had a pool there
for portions there were additional
staff there additional personnel and
that's the sort of model that we
try to keep ourselves to here i know the
cdc's website and their guidance is that
you can
gather indoors with fully vaccinated
people without wearing a mask or staying
six feet apart
that's actually for in your private home
uh so it's not workplace guidance and we
still wear masks around here just like
you are all wearing masks and
we wear masks in our offices and
continue to abide by that until that
guidance changes
thank you i'm here go ahead hi thank you
um our latest poll over the weekend
showed that the president has
a 53 approval rating which is of course
lower than any
a recent past president except for
president trump just 52
approve of his handling of the economy
why do you think that is
well first i would say there were a
bunch of polls over the weekend i know
you're asking about yours specifically
but
there are also uh some very positive
signs about the american public's a view
of the president's job he's doing
including
his response to covet and the pandemic
something that's on the minds of the
majority of the american public
according to uh the nbc poll it was 69
cbs 65 abc 64
approval uh also uh i will i will also
note
per earlier discussion that according to
the abc poll 58
of the public approved of raising
corporate tax rates
but the bottom line is the president uh
these polls show
what we have long known that the
president came into office at one of the
most divisive
moments in modern american history and
the president's focus
is on fulfilling his promise to bring
the country together so in large part on
delivering on the things
the american people were elected him to
do which there we have seen
brought approval for getting the
pandemic under control turning our
economy around
especially for working families and the
middle class so we know that bringing
the country together that getting
through what is
a a height of divisiveness in our
country is going to take some time and
that certainly we see is reflected in
the polls so when you do look at these
numbers
what lessons do you take away if any in
terms of how you may approach the next
100 days
well we the president would be the first
to tell you we have a lot of work left
to do
to get the virus under control despite
the fact that two-thirds of the public
and all of these polls uh support his
approach and support
the progress that's been made to get our
economy up and running
there's still 10 million people out of
work and people aren't feeling satisfied
by that
and we still need to keep our heads down
and keep pushing forward to get the
american jobs
plan passed and ultimately the american
family's plan
passed but also he knows that he needs
to do continue to work
at bringing the country together and he
will always be open to bipartisanship
he will always have an open door in the
oval office to uh
members of congress of different
viewpoints uh to get work done for the
american people and he certainly
believes that's what people elected him
to do and on the speech on wednesday you
know obviously if your first joint
address is a big moment for any new
president
but this is not going to be a joint
address like we've seen before because
of the pandemic a lot of the pomp and
circumstance
won't be there the audience will be
scaled down no guests etc
how is the president modifying his
approach to the speech to
sort of accommodate these unusual
circumstances you're right and
it will look very different for people
who are watching at home
who are used to seeing they may not even
know they're used to seeing this
right but they're used to seeing a full
senate chamber house and senate you know
full members of congress
uh feeling they're used to seeing guests
for all of these members of congress
they're used to seeing which is always
an important part of the speech
a uh a first ladies box that's full of
incredible
people who are inspiring have inspiring
stories and
the president references uh in his
speech
and that's tradition as well and none of
that will be
a part of the speech in the same way
that people uh have seen in the past so
there's certainly an adjustment
uh to uh you know how uh he'll speak to
the audience
speaking directly the american people at
home that's always a part of it but
even more so uh to uh you know not
having
all of these incredible stories
inspiring stories that are typically a
part of
any president's joint session or um or
uh state of the union address
so we'll look different but from his
vantage point it's still an opportunity
to speak directly to the american
people about the progress that's been
made the work that's still ahead
uh his new proposals for an american
family's plan and some of the
uh priorities that remain central to his
presidency and that hasn't changed
and you know will he be wearing a mask
because i think technically now the
rules are such that anyone speaking on
the floor
must be masked or will there be an
exception for the speech
uh you know i'll have to ask him that
and ask our doctors that's a great
question and well
let me get back to you so people can
know what to expect go ahead
thanks um quickly because i didn't get
to ask uh brian diese this
is the 1 million threshold for the
capital gains tax increase
applying to households or individuals do
you know these are all excellent
questions
and i know i put him in a very difficult
position as i am too because the speech
is not for two days and we will have
lots of briefings um that will go
through all of the specific details
so you can't clarify right now if it's
you did confirm that there will be a
capital
gains tax raised but yes and over a
million dollars so it's been reported
that's accurate but i i'm not going to
get into more specifics i will see if
there's more we can provide to you after
the briefing but we've been
quite careful about not getting ahead of
the president noted
uh another topic uh the european
commission president said
over the weekend that american
vaccinated american tourists can
uh safely enter uh with proof of
vaccination whatever
form that may be um in the summer is
there any discussion that the white
house would reciprocate that for
european travelers school constantly
reviewing uh but obviously
it is uh uh based on the advice of our
health and medical team
who are evaluating what needs to be done
to continue to protect the health and
safety of the american people so i don't
have any update on that at this point
good um canada and the united kingdom
have both
restricted travelers from india amid
concerns about the variant there
um is there any effort here or review
here about whether the us would
temporarily suspend travel from india
we're always reviewing uh what needs to
be done to protect the american people
but i don't have any restrictions or
rollback of restrictions to preview
today
one more on india um the indian
government ordered twitter and facebook
and instagram
to block social media posts criticizing
the handling of the coveted response
there
any white house comment on that book
well that certainly wouldn't be
aligned with our view of freedom of
speech around the world and will the
first lady have any kind of
virtual box or will be anything to sort
of replace the
you know the traditional as you spoke
about first lady's box full of guests
not as people knew it previously right
there won't be she won't be sitting in
the box with people
uh we are looking for ways to engage
with the american public whether it's
through viewing parties
or ways to communicate about
what the president is proposing but it
won't look or feel or
sound like it has in the past
yeah so just back on the tax question
real quick um we keep asking this
question about reconciliation
do you have a sort of a plan to increase
your outreach
to um potential skeptics even among the
democratic side
in terms of getting this um really
additionally large
package through congress sure i mean
obviously the president has uh himself
been engaged with republicans as he was
last week and i expect he will be again
next week i'll talk about the american
jobs plan as well as the american
families plan but our root focus here i
know you were asking brian about the
corporate uh opposition to
the capital gains component our core our
core focus here in the president's core
focus is on
laying out policies that will increase
investment
uh in industries of the future create
millions of jobs
invest in child care and education to
make us more competitive
then he believes we should propose ways
to pay for it but that's not he's not
doing a corporate tax proposal he's
doing an american family's
proposal an american jobs plan proposal
these are ways to pay for it
if people have alternative ways we're
open to hear from them
but the bottom line is the president's
not going to raise taxes on people
making less than 400
400 400 that would be like nobody based
taxes but
for a thousand dollars a year um and he
believes that the burden should be on
the backs of corporations and highest
level
income people who can afford to pay more
hence his opposition to
user fees and other uh proposals that
would be
uh put the weight or the the burdens on
the back of
american people and india i have another
question um actually i'm asking then it
does so
the opening up of um is that
is there any specific measure or urgency
to get doses
of the astrazeneca vaccine to india is
that
the biggest among the biggest priorities
and then on the india
specifically you mentioned that the idea
is to get some raw materials
to indian production of the astrazeneca
vaccine there are other vaccines that
are being
produced in india will those raw
materials also be available to
other manufacturers working on other
vaccines sure well on the second
question i think we
i mentioned another vaccine option
as well where the raw materials would
work for could be
useful for um but i will say that we are
continuing to look for a range of ways
to help india so we're talking about
what we can
redirect what is available now a lot of
what they need at this moment
is oxygen that is what they will tell
you uh
what um i know reporters all of you and
your colleagues who are
uh reporting from the region will tell
you uh that we are quite focused on that
as well as ppe
testing and other immediate needs they
have now but since you
since i didn't mention this earlier um
just to be clear we have
right now we have zero doses available
of astrazeneca
we're talking about what the f the fda
needs to go through a review
right to ensure the safety and it's
meeting our own bar and our own
guidelines
and we expect there to be approximately
10 million doses that could be released
if when the fda if or when the fda gives
its concurrence which could happen in
the coming weeks
so this is not immediate and there is an
estimated additional 50 million doses
that are in various stages of production
these could be completed in stages
across may and june but
our team our national security team our
covid team
working with the state department and
others we're going to assess a range of
requests
a range of needs around the world but
that's the timeline is to give you a
sense
on the putin summit is there a date that
you've got in mind
and have you made any decisions so there
was some reporting that
was you're looking at the 15th and 16th
of june which would be right after the
g7 summit is that the intention to sort
of twin those two trips and do you have
a country yet
we're not quite there yet um we are
eager of course to
um as we have any details to provide we
will provide them but
we don't have confirmation of any
details yet um or a
proposed timeline quite yet go ahead
thank you i want to follow up on
something jeff was asking about about
the second doses and then do a school
shirt
on the back end but in the second doses
the five million americans who have
missed their second dose
why does the administration think that's
happening why are people not going back
for their second shot
there are a range of a range of reasons
for different individuals i will say it
is important to note there is no
history or precedent here right so the
fact that 92 percent of people are going
back for their
second doses and our assessment is a
pretty significant number
but we are looking at ways that we can
take steps as we are for people who
haven't even taken their first dose or
their only dose if they're doing johnson
and johnson
to help address including ensuring that
we have more mobile sites
that we are as we announced last week
providing ensuring there's
an opportunity for paid leave uh that we
are working in partnership with doctors
to make it easier you know people have
busy lives uh we certainly understand
that
um and we want to take every step we can
to make it easier for
people to get their second dose their
first dose day of night in that night
they plan to do some of those things
specifically for those people who need
to go back for shot too to guarantee
that they get back in the door or
wherever they went for their first one
the same approaches apply to all of
these uh challenges
so uh obviously we target you know we
take different approaches depending on
the
community or depending on what we're
seeing in the data of the challenges
but the importance of increasing our
investment in mobile sites partnering
with doctors
partnering increasing our pharmacy
allotment
these are all steps we're taking to
increase the number of people who are
getting their doses
and on schools obviously this is a key
part of the president's 100 days agenda
nearly half of schools are open
full-time but the vast majority of
students are learning online at least
some of the time
during a week they're full-time virtual
or hybrid learning
if the buildings are open but the
students are still learning remotely
a significant portion of the time does
the president view that as a success and
will he declare that this week
well i don't think we've seen data since
the early april data that was reflective
of february
so the data is quite old at this point
in time and we've seen
across communities and states there's
been a significant amount of progress
of schools opening five days a week of
students being in school learning
now some school districts have given the
option of school of students if their
parents choose
to stay remote that is in in some school
districts the option they've chosen
i expect we'll have more data on march
not until probably early may or late
april time
that will give us a greater assessment
we have every confidence we will be over
50 percent of schools
open five days a week new data before
day 100 this week
well it's the data is done by the
department of education so we can't
really change the data release timing
but we are confident
uh given what we've seen happen across
the country that we are uh going to meet
that goal
uh go ahead david i have two questions
for you on on different topics again um
first you may have seen the fbi and dhs
turned out a fairly detailed
um set of guidance today on solar winds
and
suggested there would be more attacks uh
coming
how are we supposed to measure uh since
the president announced his sanctions
two weeks ago what success looks like
there
from the impact of sanctions impact of
the sanctions and whatever
unseen activities
well it's one thing that you know from
covering this for some time as you have
uh i will say that um you know
we have never thought seen one set of
sanctions
as being the silver bullet that would
change alone
change the behavior of the russian
government just like we wouldn't see
sanctions as the one silver bullet that
would change behavior in any country
uh we still felt it was essential to put
in place
consequences and implement consequences
for behavior that we found to be
absolutely unacceptable as did most of
the global community
uh but in terms of measuring success you
know our objective is to
de-escalate the relationship to of
course
speak out where we have concerns speak
out where we have take action as needed
uh when we are responding to uh their
behavior that we find unacceptable
but also to find a way to make it
predictable uh and stable
so i i would say you know that's what
we're working toward uh we're not
looking at the implementation of
sanctions as
a as a solo incident that we're
evaluating the success of as much as
it is part of moving and changing the
relationship
did you see putin's move to go back to
the ukraine borders
his indication that he also
as i've said before i'm blissfully not
in the mind of
vladimir putin and i uh but
you know we are and so i can't predict
or or
analyzed for you really effectively what
was in his mind in the movements that
were made but
uh our objective uh continues to be
working with our partners in europe to
uh convey that that mil that troop
buildup is unacceptable
uh that escalation is unacceptable uh
and you know president biden
uh tony or secretary blinken and others
don't hold back and making that
conveying that clearly one last question
for you you have some visitors this week
from
israel intelligence group has been
played
what are they seeing in the
administration and
um do you plan to be conveying or do
officials plan to be conveying to them
the thought that israel may be actually
actively undercutting your effort to
get back to get the iran deal back
together i'm happy to get back to you as
we try to transparent around here who
they're meeting with
and check with our national security
team about that david and others who are
interested in that
i will say that we will of course brief
them i'm certain it will be a part of
the
of the conversation as we regularly do
on the status of
negotiations we just concluded the
second round that will likely be
multi-round negotiations in vienna and
we will
update them i would expect on those
discussions and the progress being made
there but in terms of other components
of the discussion i will see
what we plan to read out from those
meetings
go ahead a few questions on behalf of
colleagues can't be here
and what about uh the capital gains tax
increase
wouldn't that take a fact again i i know
there's lots of questions and interest i
understand it i'm with you for it but we
will have
many fact sheets many pages of fact
sheets many briefings to get you all of
the details you would like
astrazeneca the doses are going to be
given specifically two countries or to
kovacs what is the process for
determining who gets those does canada
get into those
other countries sure we're working
through the what the process will look
like and we will consider a range of
options from our partner countries and
of course much of that will be through
uh direct relationships
okay um and the other question i had was
you mentioned two of the president's
goals was to
bring the country together and end the
pandemic um those are obviously the two
big goals that he has
uh yours back to work
which is and
you know you see this vaccine hesitancy
among republicans you see
uh slower vaccination rates in
republican land states
uh how are the how does the president
view those two goals as
intertwined and does you know they have
to kind of
can you not have one without the other i
guess is what i'm saying that's an
interesting question
i i would say that um the president
believes he's
got to govern for all people and that
includes of course
getting the pandemic under control which
is uh certainly not impacting people
through a political prism
uh so our efforts are to increase
vaccine has
confidence i should say uh across a
range of
uh communities where we've seen uh some
some concern or some question now we
have seen in recent data that there has
been
large increases among not just
communities of color but also
more conservative communities people who
have had a neighbor
take the vaccine who have seen the in
people who are vaccinated able to
have dinner together in in their home as
is part of the cdc guidance
and so that's encouraging but we're
going to the president is going to
continue
to govern for all people to work to
address the
crises we're facing that are not
democratic or republican crises they're
crises for the american public
whether that is the pandemic people who
are out of work
the climate crisis racial injustice in
our country
those are the four he's identified as
being central to his presidency
hi david hey jen hey a question on unity
um you know you talk about earlier you
said you wanted to bring or the
president wanted to bring the country
back
uh together so i guess the question is
uh he has not met with house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
according to kevin mccarthy uh what does
that say about unity
and also there are some other
legislative issues as it relates to hr1
and
a commission to study uh packing the
supreme court as you would say
uh and there's a lot of other lists as
well budget reconciliation so there's a
lot of folks you talk about tens of
millions of people
they're concerned about that this
doesn't seem like unity at all do you
think tens of millions of people
are concerned about him not meeting with
kevin mccarthy you know i think tens of
millions of people are concerned about
hr one and budget reconciliation and
going with the 50
vote uh threshold i think i'm not sure
the polling bears that out but i will
say
that the president's view is that
bringing the country together
is bringing the american people together
so when i say he's uh he is focused on
uh re bringing you know bringing people
together bringing democrats and
republicans together he's not talking
about
solving bipartisanship in the this zip
code here
he is talking about proposing policies
that address the crises that we're
facing
whether it's getting the pandemic under
control putting people back to work
a lot of those policies he's proposed
whether it's the american rescue plan or
the american jobs plan
are supported by the vast majority of
the american public democrat republican
independent they certainly want to see
him working with with republicans and
democrats uh
and here and he's he's absolutely doing
everything he can to do that he's had a
number of republicans
down here to the oval office uh he's
looking for it we're going to be
reviewing their proposals and
i think certainly people see that see
him rolling up his sleeves and
ready to work with people of all
different viewpoints real quick why not
separate the infrastructure bill the
republicans have whatever whatever it is
800 billion or so why not just take that
call at unity
call it a deal and then move on to some
of the other legislative parties within
within the total construct
well david as you know you need 60 votes
you can talk to
republicans in in the senate and see how
many votes they have
but i will say that where we are now is
that we are certainly
taking a look at the proposal right now
there's deep in the weeds
sometimes nerdy conversations between
staffers
members of congress we have lots of
follow-up questions i'm sure they have
lots of follow-up questions we're
sharing ideas
that's actively happening now he'll
invite some members next week bipartisan
members
to come to the oval office and have a
discussion about it and what the path
forward looks like
thank you sure good thank you ma'am um i
have one question about foreign policy
and then another about
covert here um so the first one is
in tapes obtained by the new york times
iran's foreign minister says that former
secretary
of state john kerry informed him that
israel attacked iranian interests at
least
200 times um you know as the secretary
of shifted roles
uh he still continues to represent the
united states on a world stage
does the president have any comment or
reaction to carrie telling the iranians
um about covert military action on the
part of israel
we're not going to comment on leaked
tapes okay
um and then my second question is i've
heard from a
number of governors who are frustrated
that they haven't heard directly from
president biden on these weekly
coordinating calls
why hasn't he joined those weekly calls
how many governors so what how many
governors have you heard from i've heard
from a number but has how many like how
many
one two well i'm actually curious to see
how many times he's joined those calls
and if there's
there's a reason why it was never his
but i'm i'm curious to answer to your
question too
uh i think there were two in your story
they were true in my story and there
were others who didn't go on the record
but we reflected that in the story okay
so
two governors and some anonymous
governors i will say that
the intention was never for the weekly
call
the coveted call that is led by our
covid coordinator
to be a part uh to for the president to
be leading that call
uh that the intention was for our covid
coordinator to be providing an update
directly from the president
directly from our work across the
federal government to get the pandemic
under control and what we've done in
that call is provided
weekly updates on the number of doses
that are going out to states which is
have increased
nearly every week we're talking about an
average of about 28 million out of
states now
uh it's an opportunity to have an
engagement have a discussion about
where there are challenges in the in the
system how to better operationalize
better communicate which was a complaint
that we came in and tried to
solve when uh we came into office so
that was the intention
i can assure you that uh the the
american public governors here quite a
deal
quite a great deal from the president on
his plans to get the pandemic under
control and he
is it's an excellent hands with uh with
his kovac coordinator clarify he has not
joined does he have any plans in the
future to join those calls we've never
conveyed it as a call that would be a
part of his agenda
so i'm not sure there's like a big
controversy here right thank you go
ahead
can you confirm reports that ambassador
uh sorry excuse me
cia director bill burns um was in iraq
in baghdad meeting with iranian
officials into
foreign ministers home uh i would point
you to the cia for confirmation of
anything about his schedule okay since
he was somebody who
led the discussions in 2015 and
currently prime minister i mean
to know whether foreign two of them are
planning to meet is that something that
um
we're able to discuss and again i'd
point you to uh the cia and his team
there for any details of his schedule
i have another question from guatemala
um so
earlier today secretary blinken
announced sanctions on some guatemalan
officials
are there other sanctions that the
administration is weighing for other
northern triangle countries now
and how is this expected to affect the
discussions that the vice president is
having later today
on uh migration corporation
sure well the sanctions that were
announced today which everybody may not
have seen i know there's a lot going on
is uh on one current and one former
guatemalan government official for their
role in corruption
in guatemala and these sanctions support
efforts by the people of guatemala to
end
the scourge of corruption as part of the
us government's commitment to support
improvements in government
in governance in guatemala you know and
as the vice president's virtual bilat
with the president today indicates
we are focused on working with guatemala
and other partners in the region to
improve conditions and address the root
causes
of migration today's actions were also
taken in close coordination with the
united kingdom which is today
established a new anti-corruption
sanctioned regime but we are confident
we will continue to
be able to work with the guatemalan
leadership on areas of
of agreement areas where there is
opportunity but we also are not going to
hold back
when actions warrant sanctions
as they did in this case on the grounds
of corruption do you expect the vice
president to meet with uh el salvador
president uh kelly well i know she has a
a virtual bilat next week with the
mexican president and i expect she'll
have more in the coming
weeks but i don't have anything to
preview for you today uh going all the
way
back yes i have a question for myself
and then
two for colleagues who can't be in the
room
okay first you've laid out a number of
domestic
agenda items for the president's speech
on wednesday
how much can we expect that he will
speak about foreign policy
he will certainly talk about foreign
policy in his speech and reiterate his
objectives and commitments to rebuilding
our place in the world
regaining the united states seat at the
table i don't have more to preview for
you than that but it will certainly be a
part of the speech
okay and then let me see
what is your response to the criticism
that the u.s response
to the crisis in india is coming
late well i will say first
you know the united states has been one
of the largest providers of
assistance to address the coveted
pandemic around the world
including to india and we have obviously
taken some significant steps over the
next last
couple of days to address their
immediate needs and been in close touch
with them at every level
including with prime minister and the
president discussing
or communicating i will also say that
you know we
are continuing to fight a pandemic here
india and the united states
are have two of the highest are have two
of the highest challenges as it relates
to fighting the coveted
pandemic so we also take that into
account but uh i can assure
uh people who are watching and paying
attention that we are
uh wanna work in partnership with india
we are committed to
getting them assistance they need
whether that's oxygen ppe
therapeutics tests raw materials for
vaccines
and will continue to communicate at the
highest level okay
andrea sorry oh did you want more go
ahead
is the administration concerned about
reports
on the use of forced labor to produce
polysilicon for solar panels
in xinjiang let me check i think we
would be concerned but let me check with
our national security team and we'll get
you a statement directly on that
go ahead andrew i just had a kind of a
clarification question
previously when you release doses of the
estrogenic
vaccine to canada and mexico we lose
them
you lent them is the loan thing the loan
program over are we into gifting now or
we're we're considering a range of
options and i expect as we put together
our plan and we consider
the range of requests we have and uh
determine uh where we will be
distributing these vaccines we will do
that through a range of means
and then just just on the overall issue
of
kind of vaccine production in the u.s
there is
as you know mounting pressure on the u.s
to
support this trip's waiver at the wto
has there been any shift in the u.s
position up until now the u.s has not
even permitted those discussions to take
place on a formal level
given what we're seeing now the sort of
worst case scenario
of the increased incidents in india and
so other places is there a rethink going
on i understand that there's
concern about the emergence of
variance and not knowing that you know
what will happen to those are you are
you rethinking the position now
well i'd first say and i know we'll have
a call shortly on where you can where
there'll be an opportunity to ask a lot
of these questions too but um
you know india has their own ip right um
and they are also
uh manufacturer of vaccines some of it
has been delayed um
our the last time we really communicated
about this at a high level was from our
ustr
uh katherine ty uh but i don't have any
updates to that
i might do one from a colleague yeah
you're sorry and there you go it's okay
um this is from voa who can't be here
obviously sure covet
um their question ukrainian president
zelinski is suggesting
including u.s participation to try to
end this donbass war
is the administration ready to take a
more active role in the peace process
and if yes what capacity
well i would certainly point you to the
state department they're probably the
most appropriate entity to talk about
our engagement and negotiations we have
been engaged in the past as you know
and certainly we are in close touch with
the leadership of ukraine at a range of
levels the president himself has spoken
with
uh the president of ukraine and
certainly the secretary of state and
others have spoken with their
counterparts about
what their needs are and how we can be
effective partners
thanks everyone you have eight minutes
you